j'ai donc l'honneur de vous présenter
notre proposition de loi encadrant
l'intervention des cabinets de conseils
dans les politiques publiques ce texte
est le résultat d'un travail rigoureux
de la commission d'enquête du Sénat
créée à l'initiative de mon groupe le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistique s'appuie sur 4 mois
d'investigation 40 auditions et
l'analyse de
7300 documents nous poursuivons trois
objectifs en finir avec l'opacité des
prestations de conseils mieux les
encadrer et renforcer les exigences
déontologiques des consultants il ne
s'agit pas là d'interdire par principe
le recours au cabinet de conseil mais
bien de fixer un cadre clair pour mettre
fin aux dérives constaté par la
commission d'enquête
cette démarche est transpartisane elle a
associé tous les groupes politiques de
notre assemblée je veux ici remercier
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
d'enquête pour leur soutien ainsi que la
commission des lois et ça rapporteur
c'est circuit Herman pour les
améliorations apportées au texte
c'est le plus réalise sénatorial qui
s'exprime ce soir je crois que nous
pouvons en être fiers sur tous les bancs
de notre hémicycle je souhaite également
remercier très sincèrement le président
Arnaud basin qui était fut également
président de la commission d'enquête
avec qui nous travaillons deux concerts
dès le premier jour la commission
d'enquête a mis au jour un phénomène
tentaculaire l'influence croissante de
consultant privé sur des pans entiers
des politiques publiques la crise
sanitaire la stratégie nationale de
santé l'avenir du métier d'enseignant la
mise en oeuvre de la réforme des aPL les
états généraux de la justice la liste
des missions déléguées à des cabinets
privés est tellement foisonnante qu'elle
en donne le tournis au point de se
demander si il y a un pilote dans
l'avion en 2021 la facture des
consultants s'élève à au moins un
milliard d'euros pour l'État et ses
opérateurs est la plus que doublé depuis
2018 en pratique les cabinets de
conseils n'ont pas de problème de
pouvoir d'achat une journée de
consultant coûte en moyenne 1500 euros à
l'état ce chiffre ayant atteint 2568
euros pendant la crise sanitaire malgré
ce niveau de rémunération les résultats
ne sont pas toujours au rendez-vous
Capgemini a par exemple reçu 280 200
euros pour une mission sur le handicap
alors que l'évaluation parle ce site
d'une valeur ajoutée quasi nulle parle
du cabinet bien évidemment
contre-productif parfois fin de citation
BCG et Ernst and Young ont reçu
558900 euros pour organiser une
convention des managers de l'État en
décembre 2018 qui n'aura finalement
jamais
Lucky c'est a reçu en novembre 2019 95
pour une mission commandée par par la
CNAV visant je cite encore à aider la
caisse à se transformer en vue de la
réforme des retraites alors que celle-ci
tout le monde s'en souvient a été
abandonné de telles dérives sont
inacceptables surtout lorsqu'il s'agit
d'argent public et surtout dans le
contexte actuel au quotidien l'opacité
règne sur les prestations des cabinets
de conseils qui souhaitent rester
excuser l'anglissisme biais de Sin pour
reprendre leur expression à titre
d'exemple la commission sur unique sur
les 1000 premiers jours de l'enfant
n'étaient pas au courant que l'État
avait missionné le cabinet Roland
berguerre en parallèle de ces travaux ce
cabinet a touché plus de 420 425 000
euros pour un travail qui je cite encore
n'était pas à la hauteur d'un cabinet de
stratégie selon donc l'évaluation de la
dictée dans le même temps les membres de
la commission c'est unique médecin et
experts de haut niveau étaient bénévoles
et avait du mal à se faire rembourser
leur ferait de déplacement pour se
rendre aux réunions c'était de quoi de
mesure si notre commission d'enquête a
été un exercice de transparence
démocratique on constate un retour à
l'opacité depuis au-delà de l'exercice
de communication le jaune que le
gouvernement a publié la semaine
dernière et lacunaire et je dois dire
très décevant lacunaire lacunaire car il
exclut le conseil en informatique et ne
couve que la moitié du périmètre de la
commission d'enquête il ne concerne que
470 millions d'euros de prestations
contre 894 millions dans nos travaux les
chiffres parlent de même décevant car le
gouvernement se refuse à publier la
liste de ses prestations de conseils
alors qu'il s'agit d'une information
essentielle que nos concitoyens sont en
droit de connaître en pratique les
ministères traînent des pieds pour
répondre aux demandes des journalistes
entretenant ainsi ce climat d'opacité
pour gagner du temps
l'état refuse toujours de communiquer
des documents malgré les avis les avis
favorables de la CADA le 21 janvier
dernier un journaliste de Next impact
demandait au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale une copie du rapport de
McKinsey sur l'avenir du métier
d'enseignant facturé pour une somme
exorbitante de
486800 euros dis-moi plus tard il attend
toujours le 12 octobre le journal Le
Monde annonçait sa volonté de saisir la
justice face aux non-réponses de
l'Élysée de Matignon et de la plupart
des ministères le gouvernement ne doit
pas avoir peur de la transparence bien
au contraire c'est pourquoi notre PPL
imposera la publication de la liste des
prestations de conseils de l'État et de
ses opérateurs ainsi que des bons de
commande et des évaluations de
prestations ces informations figureront
dans le rapport social unique pour que
les fonctionnaires puissent débattre les
agents publics ressentent en effet à
profond malaise lorsque des consultants
viennent leur expliquer leur métier à
coups de petite de jeux de rôle ou
encore de paper board c'est le cas à
l'OFPRA ou les consultants de wafstone
chasse qu'ils appellent des irritants
pour réduire le délai de traitement des
demandes d'asile autre exemple pendant
la campagne de vaccination
mackinsey utilisant le logo de
l'administration pour rédiger ses
livrables et Monsieur Véran ancien
ministre de la Santé d'affirmer devant
notre commission d'enquête je cite
encore si vous aviez voulu les documents
estampillés machin c'est présent dans le
dossier vous auriez trouvé une feuille
blanche c'est étrange pour une
prestation facturée plus de 12 millions
d'euros c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons
éviter toute confusion entre les
fonctionnaires et les cabinets de
conseils qui ne pourront plus utiliser
les signes distinctifs de
l'administration à l'initiative de
Michael Valette
nous proposons de bannir les expressions
anglo-saxonnes d'inspiration managériale
comme benchmark Lean Management ou
encore qu'est learning conformément à
l'article 2 de la Constitution la langue
de la République et le français y
compris pour les consultants certains
ont résumé notre texte à la PPL dites
McKinsey certes les pratiques de ce
cabinet ont choqué nos compatriotes en
particulier sur le plan fiscal 0 impôt
sur les sociétés pendant 10 ans alors
que son chiffre d'affaires atteint 450
millions par an comble de l'ironie le 11
juillet dernier sur BFM Business la
directrice générale de McKinsey rejeté
la faute sur le coup du travail en
France qui reste bien évidemment trop
élevé à son goût en réalité McKinsey
peut remercier le mécanisme des prix de
transfert le paradis fiscal du Delaware
il continue d'ailleurs de candidater au
marché public il a été désigné titulaire
de son gourmand du marché de lugap
attribué en plein été mais notre
proposition de loi va bien au-delà de ce
seul cabinet le recours au consultant
est devenu un réflexe pour
l'administration alors qu'elle dispose
des compétences en interne on a parfois
l'impression que l'État se fie davantage
au PowerPoint de ses consultants qu'au
travail de ces agents au fond le recours
croissant au cabinet de conseil illustre
une certaine vision de l'État un état en
mode start-up pour reprendre le titre
d'un ouvrage évoqué pendant l'audition
de McKinsey en délégance émissions
stratégiques à des cabinets privés létat
risque toutefois de perdre de perdre en
souveraineté au bénéfice des
multinationales du conseil nous serons
tous d'accord pour éviter à tel risque
le gouvernement lui-même a d'ores et
déjà pris des mesures la plupart du
temps en réaction à nos travaux nous
gardons bien évidemment à l'esprit la
circulaire signé le 19 le 19 janvier
dernier le même jour de l'audition
d'Amélie de Montchalin devant notre
commission d'enquête
le hasard fait parfois bien les choses
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement a
besoin de notre PPL pour mieux encadrer
le recours au cabinet de conseils vous
le savez car nous en avons nous avons eu
l'occasion d'échanger à plusieurs
reprises sur le sujet de manière franche
et directe c'est pourquoi nous vous
demandons solennellement d'inscrire
notre proposition de loi alors du jour
de l'Assemblée nationale sans en réduire
l'ambition nous avons un devoir de
responsabilité vis-à-vis des Français
qui se sont emparés du sujet et qui
souhaitent que les choses changent
l'enjeu dépasse même notre pays le 30
septembre dernier Radio-Canada annonçait
que McKinsey avait été payé 35000
dollars par jour pendant la crise
sanitaire au Québec dans l'opacité la
plus totale monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous avons ensemble le
devoir de fixer des règles plus claires
pour les consultants dans l'intérêt de
l'État et de nos politiques publiques ce
n'est pas qu'un souhait des
parlementaires que nous sommes dans
notre diversité c'est une exigence
populaire au fil des travaux de notre
commission notre débat de ce soir est
attendu et je fais confiance à notre
haute assemblée pour être à la hauteur
de cette exigence je vous remercie
la parole est à présent madame Cécile
cuquermann rapporteur de la commission
des lois
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la Commission de loi
monsieur le ministre pardon mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi de nos
collègues Eliana Sassier Arnaud basin
est ambitieuse et profondément novatrice
elle a été nourrie par les travaux que
la commission d'enquête a conduit
pendant plusieurs mois sur l'influence
croissante des cabinets de conseils sur
les politiques publiques ces travaux ont
suscité de nombreuses réactions du
gouvernement et de l'administration
comme des consultants circulaires du
Premier ministre refonte de la corps
cadre de la direction interministérielle
de la transformation publique dont
l'équipe de conseil interne doit être
renforcée rédaction par l'organisation
professionnelle s'intègre conseil d'une
charte de déontologie spécifique pour
les interventions de conseil auprès du
secteur public et très récemment
publication par le gouvernement d'une
annexe au projet de finance pour 2023
vous me permettrez monsieur ministre de
ne pas utiliser ici l'expression de
jaune budgétaire mais je pense nous
irons viendrons si ces initiatives vont
dans la bonne direction elle reste
insuffisante n'ayant pas le caractère
général et pérenne souhaité la
commission des lois estime par
conséquent qu'une loi instituant un
cadre unifié contrôlé et sanctionner est
aujourd'hui nécessaire le texte proposé
par nos collègues Eliana Sassier Arnaud
Bazin répond à 4 enjeux tous essentiels
dans le cadre d'une démocratie que l'on
souhaite mature un enjeu de transparence
vis-à-vis des parlementaires mais
surtout à destination des citoyens un
enjeu de maîtrise de la dépense publique
un enjeu de souveraineté à travers
l'action de l'État et enfin un enjeu de
probité
il a été consigné par la quasi
intégralité des membres de la commission
d'enquête et le fruit d'un travail
transpartisan la commission des lois a
donc tenu à conserver cet équilibre tout
en l'ajustant pour lui apporter une
plaine effectivité dans cet esprit elle
a sécurisé le périmètre de la
proposition de loi en choisissant une
rédaction plus précise juridiquement
préférant la catégorie des
établissements publics de l'État à celle
d'opérateurs et en évitant les
chevauchements de compétences avec les
conseils de discipline des professions
réglementées de droit
elle a renforcé l'exigence de
transparence et clarifier le partage des
responsabilités entre administration et
consultant la Commission a également
rendue plus dissuasive l'amande
administrative qui serait exigée des
personnes morales ne respectant pas les
nouvelles obligations mises en place en
la portant à un montant proportionnel
alors chiffre d'affaires mondiale elle a
enfin apporté des garanties à la
procédure de vérification sur place et
créer un mécanisme de régularisation en
cas d'exclusion des procédures de
passation des marchés publics cela étant
dit j'ai bien conscience que le texte
adopté par la commission n'est qu'un
point d'étape et non un aboutissement
certains sujets importants restent en
effet en débat mais il nécessite le
temps de la réflexion que permet la
navette et les deux bas parlementaires
il en va ainsi du champ d'application de
la proposition de loi s'agissant aussi
bien des administrations bénéficiaires
que des prestations de conseils
pour ce qui est de la liste des
administrations bénéficiaires tout
d'abord la question de l'inclusion ou
non des collectivités territoriales se
posent c'est indéniable loin de nous
d'ailleurs l'idée d'opposer un état
friand de prestation de conseils à des
collectivités territoriales qui n'y
recourraient jamais toutefois cette
question ne peut être réglée sans
consulter les associations des lieux
locaux et sans comprendre qu'elles en
sauraient les conséquences sur le
fonctionnement de ce même collectivité
territoriale nous n'allons donc pas le
faire au détour d'un amendement de
séance ce serait alors affaiblir y
compris les objectifs voulu de même la
question des feuilles est récurrente y
compris pour les établissements publics
de l'État que nous avons intégré dans le
champ d'application de la proposition de
loi cependant en l'absence d'information
permettant d'établir la liste précise
des établissements publics concernés par
tel ou telle seuil il nous semble
prématuré à ce stade fixe d'en fixer un
dans le même ordre d'idée la liste des
prestations de conseils entrant dans le
champ de la proposition de loi
mériterait très certainement d'être
affiné
ultérieurement à ce stade le
gouvernement est quelques-uns de nos
collègues ont donc formulé un certain
nombre de propositions une partie
d'entre elles remettent en cause
l'architecture du texte en particulier
le rôle accordé à la Haute Autorité à la
transparence de la vie publique et le
recours à des sanctions administratives
où reviennent sur la substance des
obligations mises à la charge de l'État
en particulier en matière de
transparence c'est pourquoi la
Commission si opposera d'autres
suggèrent des modifications plus
restreintes nous ne les avons pas
retenues à ce stade pour nous concentrer
sur le cadre général nous pourrons pour
certaines très certainement y revenir
dans la suite de la navette enfin
certains auraient souhaité saisir
l'occasion de ce texte pour renforcer le
cadre législatif s'appliquant aux
représentants ils en ont été empêchés
par l'article de la par l'application de
l'article 45 de la Constitution et
surtout là encore la volonté de
préserver l'équilibre de cette
proposition de loi
issue du travail de la commission
d'enquête ce sujet est demeure cependant
important et mériterait un texte à part
notre Comité de déontologie mène
derrière une réflexion sur les règles
applicables aux représentant d'intérêt
au Sénat
je crois que ce soir nous fixons un
cadre nous coulons en quelque sorte les
fondations mais tout ne sera pas terminé
ce soir et après l'examen du texte ici
au Sénat il y aura besoin comme je l'ai
déjà dit de poursuivre le dialogue
d'améliorer pour rendre applicable et
effective cette proposition de loi notre
rôle ici n'est certainement pas
d'affaiblir l'État et à travers lui
notre République il est au contraire de
chercher à prendre les meilleures
décisions pour changer des pratiques qui
ont conduit progressivement à
externaliser une partie de la prise de
décision vers le secteur privé
nous sommes donc pas là pour tout
renverser mais bien pour mener
pleinement notre rôle de parlementaire
celui du travail de contrôle comme celui
d'initiative législatives et donc nous
ne doutons pas que l'Assemblée nationale
fera de même fera pleinement son rôle et
inscrira et examinera dans les semaines
les mois à venir cette proposition de
loi
pour conclure la commission vous invite
donc à adopter son texte enrichi de
quelques amendements pour poser comme je
l'ai dit les premiers grands jalons de
l'encadrement de l'activité des cabinets
de conseils auprès de l'État et de ses
administrations dans un délai qui nous a
été contraint par le temps nous aurions
certainement eu loisirs de mener plus
d'auditions certainement plus longtemps
mais je crois que nous arrivons là en
tout cas après le travail de la
Commission à un équilibre qui préserve
celui souhaité par les différents
auteurs de cette proposition de loi je
tiens à remercier bien évidemment les
services de la Commission des lois qui
m'ont accompagné avec un rythme soutenu
au cours de ces quelques semaines pour
pouvoir vous présenter le rapport et ce
texte de commission ici ce soir et
j'invite très bien évidemment l'ensemble
de mes collègues a voté favorablement
[Applaudissements]
et la parole est maintenant monsieur
Stanislas Guérini ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente assassine monsieur le
Président Bazin monsieur le Président de
la Commission Jean-Noël buffet madame la
rapporteur Cécile que Karman madame les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs le
sujet qui nous occupe aujourd'hui je
veux le dire clairement et stratégique
il s'agit de la capacité de la puissance
publique à agir à répondre efficacement
au grand défi auquel nous sommes
confrontés et nous choisissons ensemble
ce soir c'est là où nous nous rejoignons
je vous en remercier
d'aborder ce sujet dans l'objectif de
renforcer la puissance publique et sans
jamais laisser ce sujet aux populistes
je veux le dire les populistes ne
cherchent qu'une seule chose créer la
polémique affaiblir le gouvernement se
faisant l'État et quand nous aurons
proposé des solutions ils passeront à la
prochaine polémique ça n'est pas
l'esprit des travaux que vous avez menés
ça n'est pas l'esprit du travail que
nous mènerons ensemble ce soir je
souhaite que nous examinions ce texte
dans l'esprit qui vous a animé de façon
trans partisane vous l'avez rappelé
madame la précisante Présidente ou
plutôt en étant rassemblé dans un seul
camp
celui de ceux qui souhaitent renforcer
l'État et sur ce sujet la philosophie du
gouvernement est claire est-ce que
l'État doit pouvoir faire appel à des
compétences dont on ne dispose pas en
interne je crois que la réponse est oui
mais est-ce que l'État doit se renforcer
doit se réarmer doit développer ses
compétences doit se doter d'un cadre
renforcé pour recourir à des prestations
de concerts externes oui je réponds
également positivement à ces questions
là et je veux saluer en démarrant nos
travaux l'engagement du Sénat et de la
commission d'enquête transpartizan créer
à l'initiative vous l'avez rappelé
madame la présidente du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste présidé par le sénateur basin
et dont les travaux ont été rapportés
par la présidente assassin vous avez
mené un travail en profondeur précise
sérieux avec des propositions concrètes
sur le sujet les membres de la
commission ont estimé que ces
propositions nécessitaient une
traduction législative le gouvernement
en prend acte et nous travaillons sur ce
texte de façon tout aussi attentive et
exigeante et je me présente ce soir
devant vous avec la volonté d'avancer
sur ces sujets et à l'appui de ces
affirmations je veux dire que nous avons
agi concrètement pour encadrer le
recours aux prestations de conseils
d'abord vous l'avez rappelé avec la
circulaire du Premier ministre du 19
janvier 2022 elle a fixé à la fois des
modalités de contrôle interne et un CAP
en matière de réduction des dépenses de
conseils à court terme nous sommes en
voie de tenir cet objectif c'est aussi
vrai des modalités de contrôle je le dis
devant la Chambre haute une mission
inter-inspection portée par la première
ministre sera mener d'ici la fin de
l'année pour vérifier la bonne de ce
point de contrôle interne et faire le
point sur ce qu'il nous reste à faire
deuxièmement dès ma nominations j'ai mis
en place un nouveau cadre clair et
renforcé sur le recours au prestations
de conseils c'est l'accord cadre
interministériel porté par la dUTP qui
entrera en vigueur en janvier 2023 et
sera d'utilisation exclusive pour les
services de l'État cet accord intègre
pleinement les recommandations de la
commission d'enquête en matière de
déontologie en matière de transparence
en matière d'encadrement des données ou
de renforcement des risques contre les
risques de dépendance des
administrations vis-à-vis des
prestataires troisièmement afin de
réarmer concrètement l'état j'ai aussi
initier le renforcement de nos moyens
humains vous l'avez souligné madame la
rapporteur en créant 15 postes dédiés au
sein de la dictée pour une
administration qui compte une centaine
de fonctionnaires aujourd'hui vous le
verrez dans les engagements budgétaires
dont vous aurez à débat dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finance j'ajoute enfin
un point très concret nous avons créé
cette année un document qui fait la
synthèse de l'ensemble des dépenses de
conseils de l'État et dont j'ai tenu
bien entendu à ce qu'il vous soit rendu
disponible avant l'examen de cette
proposition de loi ce document est
annexé au PLF 2023 je vais prendre
devant vous deux engagements concernant
ce document d'abord c'est de porter un
amendement dans le PLF 2023 dès l'examen
du texte budgétaire à l'Assemblée
nationale pour que ce document soit
gravé dans le marbre et deviennent un
jaune budgétaire pour de bons madame la
rapporteur une annexe pérenne dans le
cadre de l'examen des lois de finances
que nous aurons à examiner chaque année
le deuxième engagement j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir dans nos débats
c'est de renforcer le volume
et la précision la granularité des
informations qui seront portées à
connaissance dans ce jaune budgétaire
vous le voyez nous avançons nous
agissons nous prenons des expositions
pour renforcer l’état en prenant en
compte les recommandations du Sénat et
c'est dans cette état d'esprit que je
veux aborder la proposition de loi qui
va occuper nos travaux ce soir dans un
état d'esprit constructif sincère dans
les finalités portées par ce texte et
exigeant dans l'effectivité et la
proportionnalité des dispositions que
nous allons discuter ensemble je vous le
disais je partage l'objectif premier de
ce texte meilleure maîtrise par la
puissance publique des moyens qu'elle
mobilise et celui de neutralité des
prestations de conseil
sur la décision publique qui doit rester
pleine et entière et j'aurais affirme
tout l'intérêt de disposer d'un cadre
légal clair et stable en la matière un
point de méthode pour nos discussions ce
soir je vous dire les axes de travail
que j'identifie pour renforcer le texte
et je prends l'engagement pour les
débats qui vont suivre de toujours vous
indiquer en transparence les points qui
me semblent soit inopérant soit
disproportionné et de toujours faire des
propositions je ne porte aucun
amendement de suppression sentent contre
proposition d'une certaine façon que je
souhaiterais vous soumettre les trois
sujets que identifie sont les suivants
d'abord vous l'avez mentionné madame la
rapporteur le périmètre de la
proposition de loi établie par l'article
premier j'ai beaucoup parlé de puissance
publique j'ai fait à des saints car il
nous semble essentiels de faire en sorte
que le cadre proposé par l'article
premier s'applique également aux
collectivités territoriales qui ont
aussi recours au cabinet de conseils
nous aurons l'occasion d'en discuter
d'en discuter et des amendements ont été
portés en ce sens sur différents bancs
dans cette hémicycle deuxième sujet sur
la question de la transparence à la fois
des prestations et des compétences de
l'État le gouvernement porte des
amendements afin de recentrer en un
article unique les dispositions portées
dans les articles 3 4 et 8 il s'agit de
rendre j'aurai l'occasion de vous
présenter cette proposition plus claire
plus lisible et donc plus exploitable
les informations transmises par le
gouvernement sur le recours aux
prestations de conseils enfin troisième
sujet sur le mécanisme de contrôle
déontologique de sanctions je souhaite
que le contrôle exercé soit
proportionnelle à l'objectif poursuivi
je crois très sincèrement que c'est une
condition d'effectivité des mécanismes
proposés
nous aurons cette discussion pour les
dispositifs qui concernent les
déclarations d'intérêts exigées pour les
consultants mais aussi sur les
mécanismes de contrôle de la hatvp et la
question de la régulation des mouvements
entre secteur public et secteur du
conseil au fond je viens de vous donner
les trois champs sur lequel j'aurais des
propositions à formuler et sur lequel je
souhaite surtout que nous ayons vraiment
un vrai débat de fond pour nous assurer
de la bonne effectivement de la loi
madame la Présidente vous m'interrogez
au fond sur l'avenir de ce texte j'ai la
volonté que ce texte chemine je l'ai dit
publiquement je leur ai affirme ici
devant vous sur les modalités de son
examen que ça soit dans le cadre d'une
niche parlementaire dont la
programmation est à la main de chaque
groupe ou sur le temps réservé au
gouvernement vous comprendrez qu'il est
important pour le gouvernement que nous
puissions examiner ce texte et de voir
quel texte on parle à l'issue des
travaux que nous aurons ce soir sur
lequel la Haute Assemblée aura à se
prononcer mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs je souhaite que nous puissions
maintenant rentrer dans le débat au fond
je crois que c'est ce que vous et moi
attendons pour ce soir je vous remercie
comme Eliane assassin je souhaite
remercier tout d'abord l'ensemble des
membres de notre commission d'enquête
que j'ai eu l'honneur de présider que de
chemin parcourus depuis la réunion
consultive du 25 novembre 2021 il y a
bientôt un an notre rapport était
transpartisan tout comme cette
proposition de loi c'est à la fois un
gage de sérieux et d'équilibre partagé
sur tous les bancs de l'hémicycle je
salue également le travail de la
commission des lois qui a amélioré le
texte et je remercie leur rapporteur
pour son écoute et sa connaissance du
sujet que les choses soient claires nous
ne légiférons pas contre les cabinets de
conseil dont nous ne remettons pas en
cause le professionnalisme mais pour
mieux encadrer leurs prestations et en
finir avec l'opacité déplorée par la
commission d'enquête
aussi le gouvernement a inscrire notre
proposition de loi à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale nos concitoyens ne
comprendraient pas que ce texte se
retrouve bloqué dans la navette
parlementaire cela ne serait pas à la
hauteur des enjeux soulevés par la
commission d'enquête je vais concentrer
mon intervention sur les aspects
déontologiques ce qui ne va pas vous
surprendre
la commission d'enquête a mis en lumière
3 risques les conflits d'intérêts les
camionnettes conseils conseillant
simultanément plusieurs clients dont les
intérêts peuvent diverger la porosité
lorsque les cabinets recrutent d'anciens
responsables publics ce que l'on appelle
le pantouflage et enfin le pied dans la
porte lorsque les consultants
interviennent gratuitement pro bono pour
l'administration ce sont par exemple les
cabinets McKinsey Boston Consulting
Group qui ont organisé les sommets
techforgo des choses France à l'Élysée
ces prestations étaient même devenues
banales alors qu'elles servaient en
réalité la stratégie commerciale des
consultants avec cette proposition de
loi nous faisons choix de la clarté nous
interdisons purement et simplement le
pro bono ce que le gouvernement n'a
jamais fait seul resterait le mécénat
dans les secteurs bien circonscrits
comme l'humanitaire la culture ou
l'éducation pour plus de transparence le
mécénat fera l'objet d'une déclaration à
la Haute autorité pour la transparence
tout comme les actions de démarchage ou
de prospection commerciale des cabinets
de conseil dans la même logique nous
souhaitons que le cabinet de conseils et
les consultants remplissent des
déclarations d'intérêts sous le contrôle
de la Haute Autorité l'État est en droit
de connaître les autres clients de ces
consultants afin de mieux prévenir les
conflits d'intérêts et surtout d'y
mettre fin un état aveugle sur le plan
déontologique est un état en danger
l'enjeu n'est pas mince au regard des
récentes interventions des consultants
sur la crise sanitaire ou encore
l'évaluation de la stratégie nationale
de santé
d'un consultant on fait part de leurs
inquiétudes dans la presse les
déclarations d'intérêts seraient trop
lourdes et les forceraient à s'éloigner
du secteur public qu'il se rassure qu'il
se rassure en tant que parlementaire
nous remplissons des déclarations
d'intérêts depuis 2013 la première prend
un peu de temps puis il suffit de
l'actualiser et je pense que des bacs
puissent 10 il parviendront sans grande
difficulté
tout ça est loin d'être insurmontable je
pense que les collègues ainsi que vous
monsieur le ministre vous pourrez le
confirmer il en est de même pour le
pantouflage nous n'empêchons pas les
consultants d'aller travailler pour
l'administration et réciproquement en
revanche nous souhaitons que la vie de
la Haute Autorité soit systématique et
que l'intéressait lui rendre compte de
son activité à intervalles réguliers
pour vérifier que les exigences de la
Haute Autorité sont bel et bien
respectées rien à surmontable là encore
cela évitera par exemple qu'un
consultant de capgeministes soit
embauché au service des correspondances
de l'Élysée et recrute ce même cabinet
pour moderniser le service toute
ressemblance avec des personnes
existantes ou ayant existé mais bien sûr
pas fortuite
dans un souci d'efficacité nous
souhaitons renforcer les moyens
d'investigation et de sanctions de la
Haute Autorité cette dernière doit
pouvoir prononcer des sanctions
administratives en cas de manquement
déontologique des consultants ce qui
évitera d'engorger les tribunaux elle
pourra aussi les exclure de la commande
publique ce qui nous semble logique et
conforme au droit européen
vous voyez mes chers collègues que nous
proposons un dispositif déontologique à
la fois complet et cohérent mettant en
oeuvre les recommandations de la
commission d'enquête ou conviendrez que
la confiance de l'administration envers
ses consultants n'exclut pas le contrôle
ce qui justifie notre proposition de loi
je finirai en évoquant les représentants
d'intérêt ce sujet n'entre pas dans le
périmètre notre texte comme l'ajustement
rappeler la commission des lois je
n'ignore toutefois pas son importance ni
la nécessité de faire évoluer le droit
en vigueur c'est dans cet esprit que le
Comité de déontologie du Sénat
présentera des propositions sur les
représentants d'intérêt d'ici à la fin
de cette année après avoir entendu les
professionnels du secteur nous l'avons
commencé depuis bientôt un an et les
associations c'est un engagement que
nous avons pris auprès du bureau du
Sénat et que nous tiendrons
je vous remercie pour votre attention et
pour votre soutien à notre proposition
de loi
[Applaudissements]
et la parole est maintenant à Emmanuel
Capu pour le groupe Les Indépendants
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
nous examinons aujourd'hui une
proposition de loi issues des travaux de
la commission d'enquête menée à
l'initiative de madame la Présidente
cette commission d'enquête trouve son
origine dans une polémique né à
l'occasion d'élection présidentielle
polémique concernant le recours du
gouvernement au cabinet de conseil
certains de nos concitoyens ont en effet
été interpellés par le fait que l'État
recours à des cabinets privés pour
l'aider à définir sa stratégie
que soit ses services l'administration
n'a pas et ne peut pas avoir en interne
les compétences requises pour faire face
aux situations qu'elle doit gérer
le recours à ces cabinets permet donc
d'apporter une expertise et de proposer
des solutions
c'est ainsi que 72% des prêts des 900
millions d'euros dépensés par l'État en
conseil durant l'année 2021
concerne des prestations informatiques
tous les responsables politiques savent
bien qu'ils ont eu recours aux
prestations de conseil
ou qu'ils y auront recours un jour
et nos concitoyens Français préfèrent
sans doute que l'État prenne des
décisions éclairées
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
vise à imposer des obligations de
transparence au prestataires de conseils
lorsqu'ils travaillent au bénéfice de
l'État et de ses établissements
afin de prévenir les conflits d'intérêts
mais aussi afin d'éviter les
allers-retours entre ces cabinets et
l'administration
pour cela le texte étant le pouvoir de
la Haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie politique déjà en charge du
contrôle des principaux responsables et
agents publics ainsi que des lobbys
l'État n'est évidemment pas le seul à
recourir aux prestations de conseils nos
régions nos départements et nos communes
le font aussi très régulièrement
pour des raisons de périmètre d'enquête
cette proposition de loi ne vise
cependant pas les collectivités
territoriales
certains parmi nous s'interrogent
cependant sur la nécessité d'inclure les
plus importants d'entre elles dans ce
dispositif
en vérité notre groupe s'interroge plus
largement sur l'opportunité d'une telle
loi
nous comprenons parfaitement les
inquiétudes que l'activité de conseil a
pu susciter mais nous doutons que les
moyens proposés soient efficaces et
adaptés
l'administration fait appel à de
nombreux acteurs afin d'avoir un œil
extérieur pour résoudre les difficultés
auxquelles et les confrontées
nous croyons mais manifestement nous
sommes minoritaires et qu'il n'est pas
malsain que public et privé puissent
échanger des idées et des personnes
par ailleurs quel que soit les conseils
c'est toujours mes chers collègues le
responsable politique qui décide
et qui est responsable des décisions
qu'il prend
cela vaut également pour celle de
recourir au Conseil
nous ne sommes donc pas favorables à la
création de régime spécifique dont
l'application est confiée à des
autorités spécifiques qui disposeraient
de pouvoir d'enquête et de sanctions
spécifiques
enfin nous craignons que cette PPL ne
renforce des mots très français
création de rapport
renforcement de la lourdeur
administrative
et mécaniquement
augmentation du nombre de fonctionnaires
ça peut intéresser certains évidemment
nous sommes convaincus que notre pays a
au contraire besoin de souplesse et de
simplicité les échanges publics privés
sont monnaie courante dans beaucoup de
pays et dans ceux du nord de l'Europe
particulièrement
ils ne s'en sortent pas plus mal c'est
fertilisation croisées son créatrice de
synergies qui améliorent l'efficacité de
l'action publique
bien sûr nous devons être très attentifs
aux ressources de l'administration elle
proviennent de l'argent des Français et
doivent donc être employés à bon escient
et sans abus cela va sans dire
mais nous croyons qu'il faut également
veiller à préserver son efficacité
si nous ne voulons pas travailler
nous-mêmes à l'impuissance de
l'administration
le gouvernement a annoncé son intention
d'encadrer davantage le recours aux
prestations de conseils par les
administrations publiques et c'est une
bonne chose
l'une des manières de réduire ce recours
la plus efficace
pour les libéraux que nous sommes
c'est certainement de réduire le
périmètre d'action de l'État qui pourra
ainsi se concentrer sur ses missions
régaliennes
ces missions les plus essentielles et
sur lesquels il dispose d'une vraie
expertise
dans sa majorité vous l'aurez compris le
groupe les indépendants ne votera pas
comme Monsieur ravier ni comme certains
autres sur ce banc et s'absiendra
la parole est maintenant Guy benaroche
pour le groupe écologie solidarité
territoire
et pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame l'auteur il y a
l'assassin monsieur les rapporteurs
madame la rapporteur pardon chers
et des allers-retours trop opaques entre
les hautes sphères de l'État et les
cabinets privés avaient été clairement
une région un objectif par notre
président Emmanuel Macron
comme cela devient une habitude des
gouvernements du président de la
République en quelque peu déçu sur ce
programme malgré l'espoir de nos
concitoyens sur la réelle prison de en
côte du devoir d'exemplarité mais comme
pour d'autres décisions de cette
gouvernance je cite ce n'est pas un
échec ça n'a pas marché c'est ce que dit
couramment notre président de la
République c'est lui-même qui l'a dit
pour d'autres sujets la présente
proposition de loi s'inscrit dans
l'histoire récente des révélations
journalistiques d'une augmentation
notable des dépenses liées au cabinet de
conseils depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
d'Emmanuel Macron le groupe C RCE avait
alors demandé l'ouverture d'une enquête
sur l'influence de ces cabinets et la
présence proposition de loi s'appuie
monsieur le ministre sur les conclusions
de cette commission transpartisane
rendue au prêteur 2022
quels sont les reproches formulés à
cette explosion des recours que c'est
privé mais surtout quelles sont les
propositions que portent cette loi pour
y faire face
tout d'abord ce n'est pas le recours
même à une expertise extérieure qui est
mis au cause mais bien les mécanismes
qui amènent la transparence nécessaire à
ses contrats et les montants consacrés
pour parfois des résultats plus que
discutables le désinvestissement dans la
fonction publique qui ne résulte pas
seulement de l'action de ce président
faut l'avouer mais aussi de ses
prédécesseurs contribuent à ce recours
massif les sociétés de conseils sont
souvent perçues comme un moyen simple et
agile dans les moments de surcharge
ponctuelle pour pallier au plafond
d'emploi cela crée aux conséquences des
pertes de compétences au sein de
l'administration ou quelquefois
l'empêchement de la montée en
compétences l'exemple typique en est la
compétence informatique
certains ils voient d'ailleurs l'action
de pompiers pyromane qui ne donne pas
les moyens à l'administration de rester
compétente sur ses prérogatives dans le
but de justifier ses recours coûteux à
une poignée de grosses entreprises de
conseils pourtant une grande majorité
des entreprises de conseils de moindre
échelle restent loin du pouvoir et des
pratiques de ces grands groupes
cette dynamique de recours décuplée au
cabinet de conseil est aussi critiqué
dans son manque de transparence résultat
d'études coûteuses il y a assassine ou
la rappeler non publiée par exemple dans
l'éducation nationale
doublant de mission vous nous l'avez
également rappelé privée public par
exemple pour la prise en charge de la
petite enfance
cette opacité dans le recours que ce
soit dans la définition du besoin réel
ou dans l'effectivité réelle des rendus
et source de défiance de nos concitoyens
y compris dans notre système
démocratique au vu de toutes les
problématiques révélées par la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale qui
au-delà de marquer les dérives à pu
proposer 19 recommandations notre
collègue a donc souhaité travailler la
proposition des lois que nous vous
proposons aujourd'hui si nous apprécions
ce texte nous pensons que certains
points méritent si ce n'est amélioration
au moins une discussion je tiens par
exemple au nom de mon groupe à regretter
les décisions d'irrecevabilité quand
subit nos amendements alors qu'il
concernait explicitement les pouvoirs de
contrôle et de sanctions conférées à
l’autre autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique au vu de faire respecter
ses obligations par les prestataires de
conseils et les consultants comme
indiqué dans le document de la
commission des lois qui fixent les
règles relatives à l'application de
l'article 45 un de ces amendements est
recevable s'inscrivez de plus dans la
lignée d'une recommandations de la
mission d'évaluation de la loi Sapin de
menée en 2021 par deux députés Olivier
martex des républicains et Raphaël
Gauvin de la République en marche dans
sa proposition numéro 42 du rapport
d'évaluation il ne faisait en plus que
répandre à une demande même de la hatp
qui est explicitement dans un rapport
d'octobre 2021 à sa proposition numéro
12 demandée de doter la Haute Autorité
d'un pouvoir propre de sanction
administrative en cas de manquement à
l'obligation de dépôt d'une déclaration
d'activités la sanction est en
proportionnée à la gravité du manquement
et à la situation de la personne
poursuivie nous le regrettons vivement
déjà ce périmètre nous apparaissait
particulièrement restreinte permettant
pas une discussion globale sur les
lobbys et les liens d'intérêt entre
public et privés notre groupe est certes
minoritaire et d'autres positions hélas
parfois aussi mais le refus de
discussion au travers de décision
irrévocable d'y recevabilité pénalise
l'exercice démocratique et le lot pour
en revenir au texte à ces mesures
dovatric nous y sommes globalement
favorable
pour autant la plupart des dispositions
de cppl sont d'ordre d'orbatives mais
certaines d'entre elles revêtent un
caractère réglementaire elles ont donc
pour objectif d'inciter le gouvernement
à opérer des changements dans les règles
déontologie c'est bien là que le
bâtblesse tout comme dans lors de la
création de la hatvp c'est l'écriture
des décrets qui parfois de suit pas
c'est pourquoi nous aurons à cœur de
discuter et d'entendre les gages que
dans le gouvernement pour de réel
transformation de ce recours excessif au
cabinet de conseil les gages pour
permettre à la hatvp de pouvoir
fonctionner correctement et notre groupe
votera pour ce projet
merci chers collègues et la parole est à
Nicole Duranton pour le groupe RDPI
et pour 6 minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la rapporteur
chers collègues les pouvoirs publics ont
toujours eu besoin de s'appuyer sur des
compétences extérieures c'est une
réalité ancienne qui ne date pas
uniquement depuis l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 mais existe déjà
depuis de nombreux quinquennat et c'est
accéléré depuis 2007 RH informatique
gestion de données massives
communication analyse comparative les
besoins sont en réalité nombreux
pourquoi d'abord certains champs
d'expertise très spécial très
spécialisée le nécessite ensuite un
arbitrage apaisé appelle parfois un
regard extérieur
enfin l'urgence ou le lancement d'un
projet implique l'action rapide et
coordonnée d'un grand nombre de
consultants agissant uniquement dans un
laps de temps déterminé ce qui se prête
mal au processus de recrutement de
fonctionnaires pour autant le besoin ne
sera pas toujours aussi important que
durant la crise covid d'une part nous
avons vécu ces dernières années dans une
accumulation de crise globale tout à
fait inédite d'autre part chaque
administration travaille son
attractivité afin de recruter en interne
ses compétences je vous laisse également
souligner que nous nous ne sommes pas
les plus mauvais élèves en Europe ainsi
en 2018 un rapport souligne que comparé
aux autres pays européens le conseil au
secteur public apparaît limité en France
les chiffres sont cinq fois plus je vais
en Allemagne et 4 fois plus au
Royaume-Uni
la résolution numéro 111 a été
enregistrée à la présidence du Sénat le
27 octobre 2021 une commission d'enquête
a ensuite été constituée donc cette
commission dont j'étais membre a entendu
pendant 4 mois 47 personnes sous serment
lu les réponses à 131 questionnaires et
analyser 7300 documents comme mes
collègues l'ont déjà souligné le rapport
a été rendu le 16 mars dernier et je
salue le fait que le gouvernement ait
pris en considération les
recommandations lors de l'élobe
l'élaboration du nouvel accord cadre
plafonnant les dépenses de conseil
renforçant la transparence et améliorant
l'évaluation par ailleurs le
gouvernement adore est déjà publié un
jaune budgétaire annexé au PLF 2023 et
intitulé recourt au conseil extérieur
il s'agit là d'un pas supplémentaire
vers plus de transparence compétences
souveraineté démocratie et légitimité de
la décision voici autant d'enjeux que
cette pratique implique et qu'il
convient de sécuriser le Premier
ministre avait déjà publié le 19 janvier
une circulaire portant l'objectif
ambitieux de diminuer de 15%, le volume
de prestation de conseil en stratégie en
2022 toutefois les dispositions
concernant la transparence méritait
d'entrer dans le champ législatif je
salue le travail préalable en 2014 et
2015 des rapporteurs pour information de
la commission des finances sur la
communication de la Cour des comptes le
mercredi 12 octobre la commission des
lois a adopter à l'unanimité la PPL
cabinet de conseil tous les amendements
de la rapporteur ont été adoptés
également cette proposition de loi vise
à traduire dans la loi les
préconisations de la commission
d'enquête assurer la traçabilité de la
participation des cabinets et garantir
une meilleure information des citoyens
mais en aucun cas à supprimer le Conseil
notre groupe le RDPI souhaite apporter
quelques modifications au texte en
déposant 5 amendements le premier
amendement que nous proposons précise
dans l'article 1er le seuil des
établissements publics concernant par le
chant de la PPR en effet il est
essentiel d'éviter de faire peser une
charge déraisonnable sur des structures
de taille réduite 60 millions cela
correspond au seuil des avances
obligatoires versées au PME dans le
cadre d'un marché public seuil déjà bien
connu des acteurs concernés le second
vise à exclure les prestations des
conseils internes à l'administration
pour éviter une sur interprétation par
le juge le troisième réaffirme
l'exclusion des prestations de gestion
RH et d'expertise informatique
concernant l'article 11 nous portons un
amendement pour que les modalités
d'enregistrement des actions de
démarchage soit définie par décret
l'objectif étant d'aligner le dispositif
sur les règles de droit commun enfin sur
l'article 18 il s'agit de limiter les
obligations d'audit souvent très
coûteuses au marché les plus sensibles
qui le nécessitent durant les travaux de
la commission a été développé l'idée
d'appliquer le dispositif au
collectivités territoriales en effet les
régions les départements les EPCI et
certaines villes font aussi appel au
conseil et cela s'inscrit dans la suite
logique des choses toutefois cette
extension du champ de la loi doit passer
par la fixation d'un seuil le
gouvernement est plusieurs collègues des
différents groupes ont déposé des
amendements portant ce seuil à 100 000
habitants ce chiffre semble tout à fait
adapté je sais que notre ministre
Stanislas Guérini aura à cœur de ne pas
dévitaliser le texte de la commission il
convient de rendre visible l'action de
chaque acteur des politiques publiques
d'empêcher toute dérive mais aussi de ne
pas tomber dans la surenchère
législative de ne pas ajouter
différents niveaux une surcharge de
travail et des règles confuses le groupe
RDPI est favorable sur le principe de
cette proposition de loi nous serons
très attentifs au vote des différents
amendements le texte issu des travaux de
la commission est équilibrée et
s'inscrit dans la continuité logique des
travaux de la commission d'enquête il
sera nécessaire de veiller à ce que le
dispositif puisse facilement être mis en
place par l'administration en alignant
le plus possible sur ce qui existe déjà
pour les représentants d'intérêt je vous
remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mais monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur chers collègues je
voudrais d'abord au nom du groupe
socialiste remercier très sincèrement
nos collègues Éliane assassis et Arnaud
Bazin pour avoir fait avec tous les
membres de la commission d'enquête un
travail tout à fait remarquable et ce
travail remarquable illustre une fois
encore mes chers collègues combien le
Parlement est particulièrement le Sénat
peut être
utile et efficace lorsqu'il exerce
pleinement la mission de contrôle qui
lui est dévolue par la Constitution
donc merci pour ce travail ce travail a
permis notamment l'ouverture d'une
enquête judiciaire suite à la découverte
du non-paie d'impôt sur les sociétés
entre 2011 et 2020 par le cabinet
mackinsey alors qu'il réalise en France
un chiffre d'affaires annuel de
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
c'est il acceptable
impossible que cela continue ainsi nous
avons également grâce à la commission
d'enquête découvert que l'État avait
dépensé en 2021 plus d'un milliard
d'euros on peut rester station de
conseils de cabinet privé
45% de plus
qu'en 2018 nous avons découvert que par
rapport à la crise sanitaire il avait
été fait largement conseil appel à ces
cabinets or mes chers collègues nos
services les services de l'État
disposent de compétences considérables
et il est parfois regrettable que l'on
fasse appel à des instances privées
alors que les services publics disposent
des compétences nécessaires
je vous l'ai dit aussi que
un jour
j'ai appris
qu'un ministre avait fait appel à un
cabinet de conseils pour rédiger
l'exposé des motifs d'une proposition de
loi d'un projet de loi
c'est absolument
insupportable si un ministre ne peut pas
rédiger les raisons pour lesquelles il
présente une un projet de loi alors
c'est un désespéré de la politique donc
ne mélangeons pas tout il est vrai qu'il
est des domaines dans lesquels il est
utile de faire appel à des compétences
extérieures à l'administration personne
ne le conteste mais encore faut-il que
ce loi ce que cela soit fait en toute
transparence alors mes chers collègues
nous avons déposé nous aussi quelques
amendements pour élargir le champ alors
je sais bien qu'on nous a dit Madame la
rapporteur vous nous avez dit finalement
il nous est apparu plus sage de nous en
tenir strictement au champ de la
commission d'enquête chantant cet
argument mais rien n'empêche le
législateur que nous sommes d'aller plus
loin absolument rien
et si les principes sont bons au terme
des travaux de la commission d'enquête
pourquoi ne pas élargir le champ c'est
pourquoi nous avons nous aussi penser
aux collectivités locales d'une certaine
importance chers collègues plus de
100000 habitants nous avons pensé à la
Caisse des dépôts et conciliation et
nous avons aussi pensé aux assemblées
parlementaire parce qu'en fin ne
serait-il pas logique que nous
appliquions à nous-mêmes les excellentes
règles qui ont été formulées dans le
rapport
c'est une question alors nous savons
déposé un amendement en prenant soin
dans sa rédaction j'insiste là dessus
qu'il préserve intégralement l'autonomie
des assemblées parlementaires
c'est-à-dire que c'est le bureau de
chaque assemblée qui décidera des
modalités de mise en œuvre en tout cas
il nous apparaît on pourra en discuter
bien entendu et diverses méthodes sont
peut-être possibles pour atteindre ce
but le but c'est quoi c'est la
transparence et nous avons grand intérêt
dans ce domaine comment beaucoup
d'autres
à jouer la carte de la totale
transparence à l'égard de nos
concitoyens il est un livre très ancien
qui a connu quelques succès et je
terminerai l'assume monsieur le
Président et Madame la rapporteur dans
laquelle on peut lire cette phrase la
vérité vous rendra libre je vous
remercie
merci et la parole est à monsieur Éric
Bocquet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste pour
également 5 minutes
ce président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues et les cabinets de
conseils privés acteurs de l'ombre
omniprésent pourtant tentaculaire à
juger la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale ont été démasquées dévoilés
mis au grand jour les parlementaires du
groupe CRCE sont à l'origine ils ont
conduit par le biais de notre présidente
avec les membres de la commission
d'enquête c'est le président Arnaud
Bazin une investigation qui je le dis
nous a dépassé nous a dépassé d'abord
par la résonance populaire que les
travaux ont eu les cabinets de conseils
constituent désormais un objet politique
identifié et controversé nous devons
collectivement nous en féliciter elle
nous a dépassé aussi par l'impérieuse
nécessité de légiférer rapidement c'est
ce que nous ont ce soir pour traduire en
acte les constats partagés par les
membres de la commission d'enquête à
l'unanimité
si le recours a des cabinets de conseils
est ancien son ampleur est inédite un
milliard d'euros en 2021 ce qui diffère
d'hier c'est surtout une croyance
toujours plus affirmée qui transparait
depuis le début du premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron entre ceux qui savent
et ceux qui ne savent pas les sachants
étant les cabinets de conseils les
autres sont dans l'administration
le monopole de la vérité objectif est
rationnel incombrait à des cabinets
connus pour appliquer à des problèmes
différents les mêmes recettes économie
d'échelle oblige
nous nous souvenons des mots de Nicolas
Sarkozy ancien président de la
République le 12 décembre 2007 dès les
premiers mots de sa présentation de la
fameuse révision générale des politiques
publiques je cite la réforme de l'étage
les promises je la ferai je la ferai
parce que nos finances publiques doivent
être redressées
ces mots matérialisés par le nom et non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
ont porté un coup important à la
capacité de la fonction publique de
menera bien ses missions chacun
reconnaît aujourd'hui que la dérive est
allée beaucoup trop loin il faut
consacrer le retour du politique comme
maître de l'action publique nous fume
bien les seuls à proposer dans le cadre
de l'examen de la révision de la Golf du
28 décembre 2021 relative à la
modernisation de la gestion des finances
publiques la suppression de la
fongibilité asymétrique terme barbare
qui permet de redéployer les budgets du
personnel vers des dépenses différentes
investissements intervention ou
Consulting entre guillemets
permettez-moi cette anglicisme mais qui
interdit le mouvement inverse cette
logique libérale est mortifère je
souhaite que tous nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens défis ces mécanismes
libéraux de réduction de l'emploi public
au prétexte une prétendue obésité de
l'État
le collectif nos services publics
explique cet effet pervers de diminuer
le coût du service tout en maintenant sa
qualité on en réduit la qualité tout en
dégradant les finances publiques fin de
citation par le fait notamment de
rémunération beaucoup plus élevée pour
les cabinets de conseil
feignant de soutenir la proposition de
loi transpartisanes du Sénat le
gouvernement et ses alliés révèle leur
volonté de miner le texte quelque part à
grands coups d'exclusion et de
suppression on ne peut pas prétendre
encadrer le recours au cabinet de
conseils en même temps leur faire
béattement confiance on ne peut pas
prétendre encadrer les cabinets de
conseil et en même temps exclure des
consultants au titre de leur statut on
ne peut pas prétendre encadrer le
recours au cabinet de conseils en même
temps saper les obligations
déontologiques que prévoit la présence
proposition de loi pour départ
donnez-moi monsieur le ministre mais
votre en même temps n'est pas
l'équilibre c'est le laxisme c'est la
poursuite de la connivence entre le
cabinet de conseils et le gouvernement
les contrats massifs passés durant l'été
et en ce début l'automne montre que vous
n'avez tiré jusqu'ici aucune leçon sur
le fond des travaux de la commission et
entendez bien vous limitez à des
déclarations d'intention
tout au long du processus vous n'avez eu
de cesse de miner les travaux de la
Haute Assemblée s'entend que la
situation vous échapper quelque peu
publication d'un rapport à l'assemblée
circulaire opportunes la veille d'une
audition du ministre conférence de
presse de ministre en pleine campagne
présidentielle et publication d'un jeune
budgétaire incomplet avant même le vote
de la proposition de loi les mots du
président alors candidats sont teintés
de vérité sur mckinsee on est mauvais
comme des cochons les enfants je prends
un instant car vous connaissez mon
appétence en matière de lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et toutes les formes
d'optimisation intolérable la Commission
a prouvé que mckinzey ne payait pas
d'impôts sur les sociétés depuis 10 ans
alors même que celles qu'on appelle la
firme réalisée plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
chaque année est capté de l'argent
public merveilleux Delaware qui compte
970 000 habitants et un million 600 000
sociétés enregistrées chers collègues
nous sommes fiers de ce texte fiers de
l'esprit de construction transpar design
qui nous a animé c'est un point de
départ bienvenue pour celles et ceux qui
pensent encore que l'État peut et que
l'État doit garantir l'intérêt général
la parole est à présent à Madame
Nathalie Goulet pour l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président
ministre le président et commission des
lois même le rapporteur arrivé en 9e
position beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
dites je voudrais revenir sur sur nos
travaux avec quand même une petite
aigreur c'est pas avoir eu l'idée
moi-même de cette commission d'enquête
j'en ai une très grande frustration et
je remercie yen assassy et son groupe
d'avoir eu cette idée que je n'avais pas
eu je m'étais limitée lors d'un rappel
au règlement à un débat sur le sujet et
voilà que la commission d'enquête est
arrivée le sujet mérite et les travaux
de notre commission d'enquête dont j'ai
eu l'honneur d'être vice-présidente en
sont le témoin mérite qu'on s'y soit
penché le sujet est important au plan
financier la part du privé dans la
décision publique dans quelles
conditions sous quel garantit c'est un
sujet qui n'est pas que philosophique
tant notre société est friante est
ouverte au conflit d'intérêt qui sont à
mon sens le pire cancer de la politique
encore une fois il n'a jamais été
question d'interdire le recours au
cabinet conseil mais de encadrer ses
recours pour plus de transparence afin
d'assurer une plus-value réelle sans
l'interdire on peut s'interroger sur le
fait que l'état de plus en plus recours
à ses cabinets y compris pour les
politiques publiques les plus sensibles
c'est une tendance à
ubériser le pouvoir régalien qui est de
mon point de vue relativement
inquiétante c'est une philosophie dont
certains dont je fais partie
non quelques en difficulté à accepter
placardiser la haute fonction publique
en lui préférant à prix d'or des
cabinets extérieurs privés c'est
dévaloriser ces paupériser la haute
fonction publique et les inspections
générales dont nous savons très bien
qu'elle regorge de compétences souvent
et rarement écouté ou entendu en page 39
du rap en page 39 du rapport vous avez
une déclaration de Martin Hirsch qui a
confirmé du malaise que peuvent
ressentir les agents autant le fait de
travailler y compris dans le corps
médical sur un projet donné avec un
regard extérieur ne pose aucun problème
autant le fait d'avoir une sorte
d'abonnement auprès de grands cabinets
de consultants et de personnes pour
lesquelles l'hôpital n'est qu'un client
n'était pas perçu politiquement en page
très du rapport les agents de l'offre à
déclarent ainsi j'ai l'impression que
nous sommes régulièrement infantilisés
il faut rappeler qu'un cabinet conseil
pour ce sujet fournissant une prestation
pour réduire les délais traitements des
demandeurs d'asile délai qui n'est
toujours pas réglé d'ailleurs
aperçu à 485 818 euros la valeur ajoutée
n'est pas immédiatement perceptible
moderniser ce n'est pas paupérisé comme
moderniser notre diplomatie n'aurait pas
dû être un petit matin d'un petit lundi
de Pâques de supprimer la fonction le
corps diplomatique ni de supprimer les
nains ni le corps préfectoral au 1er
janvier 2023 je ne crois pas à ces
réformes en faux qui ne sont que des
réformes en trompe l'oeil d'ailleurs
jamais évalué donc le sujet n'est pas
uniquement technique il est politique et
donc c'est à juste titre le groupe CRCE
s'y est penché le gouvernement a
d'ailleurs été contraint de réagir face
aux travaux en toute transparence avec
des auditions ouvertes au public qui
sont toujours en ligne le 19 janvier
2022 sous la rubrique il faut sauver le
soldat Montchalin une
circulaire a été publiée le matin même
de l'audition même pas la veille pour
limiter le recours des ministères au
cabinet conseil circulaire insuffisante
mais attestant
de la gêne on peut se le dire on est
entre nous il est tard du gouvernement
face aux effets de nos auditions
publiques bon un mot sur le périmètre
alors là je suis prise une double
sincérité franchement sans triste
il est évident il est évident que la
question des collectivités locales se
pose elle se pose il y a pas il y a pas
de volonté de ne pas traiter la question
des volontés de des collectivités
locales mais pour les régions les
départements les grandes métropoles les
intercommunalités c'est un sujet
à part entière et nous ne l'avons pas
traité durant notre commission d'enquête
nous n'avons pas eu une seule audition
sur le sujet nous avons consulté aucune
des associations d'élus c'est pourquoi
notre groupe sur ce sujet s'absiendra
sur les amendements
pour une raison très simple hein ça n'a
pas été traité lors de la commission
d'enquête mais surtout les associations
des lunes n'ont pas été consultés et
donc de notre point de vue il est tout à
fait inacceptable de les de les intégrer
dans ce dispositif sans avoir été
entendu donc notre commission d'enquête
à Clermont défini le périmètre la loi a
en cas la proposition de loi est cadrée
sur les travaux de notre commission
d'enquête les collectivités locales je
vous l'accorde monsieur le ministre et
j'accorde à mes collègues qui ont déposé
les amendements c'est un vrai sujet je
pense que de ce point de vue là on
pourra avoir une autre mission une
mission flash monsieur le ministre vous
pouvez nommer quelque parlementaires en
mission sur le sujet on pourra
d'ailleurs travailler aussi sur les
centrales d'achat ce sera aussi
important sur les prestations de
conseils et le recours au cabinet
d'avocat le Conseil National des
Barreaux c'est vantés sur les réseaux
d'avoir obtenu un résultat et d'être
exclu du périmètre de contrôle voilà le
tweet mortifère du Conseil national nous
ven de faire modifier la proposition de
loi sur l'encadrement des cabinets dit
de conseils cette proposition
sénatoriale prévoyait d'englober dans
son périmètre les prestations de
conseils juridique oui mais enfin
monsieur le ministre vous savez que sur
les directives européennes nous avons eu
exactement le même type d'irritant
lorsque des cabinets d'avocats montent
sujets chers à mes collègues du groupe
communiste républicains et citoyens et à
Eric Bocquet tout un tas de pyramides
pour faire de l'optimisation voire de de
la fraude fiscale il était évident qu'il
fallait les rentrer dans les dispositifs
légaux donc bon le texte est comme ça
pour l'instant mais je pense que sur ce
sujet il faut travailler il faut
travailler avec les bâtonniers il faut
travailler dans le domaine réglementaire
et il faut améliorer les dispositifs de
transparence vous ne pouvez pas
consulter un cabinet d'avocat sur la loi
sur les mobilités en ignorant absolument
s'ils sont ou pas l'avocat de telles
compagnie de vélibres ou de tel autre
société pour lequel il y aurait sinon
des conflits d'intérêt du des liens
d'intérêt qui posera un certain nombre
de problèmes je pense que ce sujet est
un sujet extrêmement important et qu'il
faut le traiter parce que encore une
fois comme je l'ai dit au début de mon
intervention le conflit d'intérêt et de
mon point de vue
le pire cancer de la vie publique alors
un petit mot sur l'article 8 quand même
qui va provoquer quelques remue-mère
c'est des nouveaux évidemment pouvoir de
la Haute Autorité de la transparence de
la vie publique bon moi je considère que
c'est une bonne disposition
et puis
il y a eu aussi un problème monsieur le
ministre pendant les débats auxquels
j'ai quand même été relativement
présente
toutes ces toutes ces toutes ces
prestations de conseils n'ont absolument
aucune coordination ni avec France
stratégie ni avec le Commissariat au
Plan
et je dois dire que ce défaut
d'articulation nous a laissé intentiner
songeur donc le rapport fourmi de 7300
documents 4 millions d'euros pour
McKinsey 41 millions pour 68 commandes
pour la crise sanitaire 485000 euros
pour l'étude sur la réduction du temps
des attentes des demandes d'asile dont
on sait très bien que ça n'a pas du tout
fonctionné sans parler de McKinsey agent
de liaison entre l'État et les agences
de santé publique pour 169
4440 euros n'est ce pas pour 5 mois
d'études tout cela nous semble pas du
tout raisonnable je pense que cette
commission d'enquête est une excellente
plus value pour notre Haute Assemblée
que c'était c'est une haute plus-value
pour le travail parlementaire et c'est
une haute plus-value pour le travail
républicain que nous menons je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre en effet la
question illégitime et c'est une des
premières questions que nous nous sommes
posées avec Hélène assassin après la fin
des de la commission d'enquête pour
savoir ce que nous allions retenir dans
la propositions de loi dont nous des
bâtons ce soir nous est assez vite
apparu qu'il ne fallait pas inclure les
collectivités territoriales pour les
raisons qu'à rappeler la rapporteur mais
je voudrais insister sur deux points qui
sont à mon sens tout à fait déterminant
le premier point c'est que l'influence
des cabinets de conseils sur l'état
concernent à l'évidence des sujets
beaucoup plus vastes y compris dans le
domaine de la défense nationale ou dans
le domaine sanitaire elles intéressent
toute la nation tandis que les décisions
prises dans un département ou dans une
région s'ils ne sont pas négligeables
sont quand même beaucoup plus limités
dans leurs conséquences et puis surtout
surtout pourquoi est-ce que nous sommes
là parce que nous avons constaté qu'il
nécessaire de renforcer la transparence
on a des transparence contrôle du
recours déontologie mais le premier
point c'est la transparence et il nous a
fallu tous les outils d'une commission
d'enquête avec tous ses pouvoirs qui ne
sont pas minces auditions sous serment
communication obligatoire des documents
vérifications sur place et sur pièce
pour savoir ce que de l'État dépensait
en matière de cabinet de conseils de
consultant il nous a fallu tout ça donc
pour avoir notre rôle de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement il nous a fallu
tous ces moyens nous avons prévu de les
entrer de les faire rentrer dans la loi
mais que se passe-t-il dans les
collectivités territoriales il y a des
assemblées délibérantes il y a des
oppositions il y a des communications
obligatoires de documents quand j'étais
président du département du Val-d'Oise
j'ai fourni à mon opposition tout un
ensemble de documents et ils ont le
compte administratif les contes de
gestion par ailleurs et puis il y a
aussi l'encadrement par les services de
l'État par la trésorerie qui vérifie que
les décisions sont conformes à ce qui a
été voté donc il y a tout un appareil
tout un contre-pouvoir qui est déjà en
place dans les collectivités locales ça
n'empêchera pas de se pencher sur sur le
sujet mais je veux dire que les choses
sont absolument pas symétriques et
absolument pas comparables c'est
pourquoi nous avons choisi de ne pas
retenir les collectivités territoriales
ensuite madame assassine oui très
rapidement parce que le président bazar
vient de dire à un certain nombre de
choses que je souhaitais également dire
c'est normal puisque nous avons
travaillé ensemble mais je crois que il
faut quand même rappeler qu'avec la
commission d'enquête nous avons
documenté l'influence des cabinets de
conseils sur monsieur le ministre les
décisions de l'état de ces
établissements publics et de ce et des
hôpitaux nous avons aussi intégré les
hôpitaux dans les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête sur les
collectivités aujourd'hui parce que
j'entends bien évidemment les
amendements qui sont déposés par nos
collègues et je pense qu'il ne faut pas
être sur la défensive sur sur le sujet
il faut savoir l'aborder frontalement et
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous avons été plusieurs à émettre
l'idée que le monsieur le ministre
puisse rencontrer les associations
d'élus pour avoir un échange approfondie
avec elle sur ce sujet et que cela
puisse sans doute peut-être faire
l'objet d'un d'un mort on a parlé je
crois que c'est Madame Goulet tout à
l'heure qui proposait pourquoi pas une
mission flash mais des parlementaires
pourraient aussi demander une commission
une mission d'information une commission
d'enquête sur le sujet parce que c'est
un vrai sujet on ne se le cache pas il y
a des collectivités parmi les plus
importantes qui effectivement ont
recours à des cabinets privés mais
aujourd'hui nous n'avons aucune aucune
donnée consolidée sur le niveau des
dépenses de Conseil des Collectivités
Territoriales puis monsieur le ministre
excusez-moi mais il y a quand même un
paradoxe avoir à vous voir très disposer
pour étendre la PPL au collectivités
alors que vous avez déposé plusieurs
amendements pour réduire l'ambition de
notre texte sur ses propres services
et enfin Madame Gatel
si monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la rapporteur
je voudrais tout d'abord à mon tour me
réjouir du travail qui a été conduit par
les présidents assassin et basins je
trouve que ça illustre parfaitement la
capacité du Sénat à dépasser l'écrivage
à prendre le temps de travailler sur le
fond sur des vrais questions et des
sujets importants monsieur le ministre
moi je partage la nécessité pour l'État
comme pour les collectivités de recourir
à des expertises extérieures et en tout
cas il n'est pas dans l'intention du
groupe centriste de pratiquer une sorte
de chasse aux sorcières maintenant nous
sommes tous d'accord sur la nécessité de
plus de transparence
d'exigence et de contrôle monsieur le
ministre vous avez raison se pose la
question des collectivités il ne
faudrait pas que quelqu'un en nous
écoutant ce soir il a l'impression que
nous nous dérogions et que nous voulons
échapper à la transparence c'est pas le
de la maison et cette autre chambre
voilà mais monsieur le ministre vous
avez salué la qualité la rigueur du
travail qui a été fait la qualité et la
rigueur conduisent avoir eu une
expertise une évaluation faire des
propositions maintenant la mission elle
a écarté de son champ de travail les
collectivités maintenant vous voyez bien
que nous disons tous qu'il y a un champ
investiguer mais pardonnez-nous nous
n'allons pas décider à la hussarde à 24
heures enfin même un peu plus de ce
qu'il va arriver au
collectivités alors même que nous ne les
avons pas entendu et que nous ne cessons
vous comme nous y compris le président
de la République et les collectivités de
déplorer le fait qu'il peut arriver à
quelqu'un prendre une décision sur un
coin de table ou au coin d'un fauteuil
d'imposer puis après on se dit zut ça ne
marche pas donc monsieur le ministre
d'ailleurs si je puis me permettre son
malice je me demande pourquoi sur votre
amendement il manque les métrop parole
de Marseille et de Paris qui ont un
statut particulier mais peut-être ai-je
mal lu la votre proposition et qu'on
voit bien qu'on a un éventail de
proposition qui nécessite monsieur le
ministre avec sérieux et avec exigence
d'aller investir mais ce soir je pense
que vous seriez le premier à recruter ce
que nous pourrions faire parce que
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions
donc que la mission soit poursuivie ici
ou que l'Assemblée nationale prenne le
sujet moi je suis ok mais sincèrement on
peut pas décider d'un truc comme ça sans
en avoir parlé aux associations des
lieux merci monsieur le président
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues d'abord vous dire
j'ai été maire j'ai été président d'une
intercommunalité j'étais président d'un
syndicat mixte et j'ai été président
d'un département également vous dire que
j'ai pu constater des dérives en matière
de recours à des cabinets conseils et je
fais un pas par rapport aux enjeux
déontologiques je parle plutôt sur le
contenu de ce recours parce que il est
parfois fait recours parce que la loi
suscite ce recours à des cabinets
conseils à travers des exigences telles
que les rapports d'un certain nombre de
documents stratégiques de développement
ou autre à travers des documents
d'urbanisme et que cela peut avoir des
conséquences particulières tout d'abord
la standardisation des approches sur la
manière d'aborder les sujets on a des
formes de peu de copier-coller alors
sinon matériel au moins intellectuel à
un moment où il nous faut repenser
l'ensemble des concepts l'ensemble des
compromis sur les différents enjeux de
société
également et évoqué souvent par rapport
à des documents ou en tout cas des des
schémas qui ne sont comment exigés une
absence parfois une insuffisance de
maîtrise des travaux par les
fonctionnaires de la collectivité
territoriale parfois par les élus qui
conduit à une forme entre guillemets de
délégation de pouvoir il s'agit à
travers effectivement ce regard sur
l'intervention des cabinets conseils de
s'assurer que on n'a pas cette facilité
du recours au Cabinet des conseils et
que ce soit effectivement réservé là où
il est nécessaire d'avoir des expertises
en particulier techniques nécessaires
pour pouvoir mener et définir les
politiques locales
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
minier juste un mot pour pour compléter
ce qu'a dit Françoise guettal tout à
fait légitimement est-ce que j'avais
annoncé à la tribune de d'une double
sincérité très centriste nous allons
nous abstenir sur l'ensemble de ces de
ces amendements parce qu'effectivement
il y a un sujet donc il est pas question
de voter contre et en même temps le
périmètre de la mission et la nécessité
d'avoir des auditions et un travail plus
précis fait qu'on ne peut pas voter pour
donc nous abstiendrons
les discussions que nous avons sont très
intéressantes elles démontrent le fait
que ce texte est extrêmement complexe
d'un côté on dit la notion de
déontologie est une n'est pas une notion
de chiffre d'affaires ou de budget de
fonctionnement et donc on ne peut pas
l'appliquer aux établissements publics
administratifs de plus de 60 millions
d'euros de budget
seulement et de l'autre on dit on ne
peut pas
appliquer
cet article aux collectivités
territoriales qui ont 100 000 habitants
c'est-à-dire un budget de fonctionnement
de près de 500 000 euros au moins
et on a dit aussi que la déontologie
elle commençait le conflit d'intérêt il
commençait dans c'était le cancer de
l'institution on voit bien et la
définition d'article le démontre qu'on a
une difficulté
à faire le périmètre et qu'il conduit en
fait un peu tout et son contraire sur le
même article c'est la raison pour
laquelle il me semble que ce texte n'est
pas prêt c'est la raison pour laquelle
je m'abstiendrai
non simplement sur quelques éléments qui
qui ont été apportées
je pense que jusque là
chacun a évité de caricaturer les propos
des autres donc il est important que
nous puissions d'abord continuer à
avancer ainsi donc voilà je pense
qu'aucun collègue ici
Nadi a aucun moment donné que la
question des collectivités territoriales
n'en était pas une la seule chose sur
laquelle je crois plusieurs alertes tout
d'abord
notre collègue Arnaud Basel rappelait
précédemment il existe aujourd'hui des
mécanismes alors je ne sais pas si on
doit dire de contrôle de régulation de
transparence ou d'information dans les
collectivités territoriales qui sont
différents de ceux qui sont mis
aujourd'hui dans la plupart des
administrations de l'État deuxièmement
cela a été dit par Madame Assassi par
Madame Gatel par un certain nombre
d'autres la volonté que cette question
des collectivités territoriales notre
collègue Richardt également
ne soit pas simplement entre guillemets
la roue tour nous correspondant à tel
référence à l'article du code général
des collectivités territoriales mais
qu'il y ait plus largement une expertise
et surtout une réflexion avec celles et
ceux qui au quotidien les administres
c'est à dire les élus les élus locaux en
situation
d'exécutif aujourd'hui et puis mais je
le redis c'est à dire parce que je viens
d'entendre ce qui ce qui a été dit par
notre collègue Capu mais non aujourd'hui
cette proposition de loi
si on rentre les collectivités
territoriales effectivement j'aurai
envie de dire je pourrais vous donner
raison tout un certain nombre d'articles
vont devenir
complètement incompréhensible mais par
exemple effectivement qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de ce que l'on exige à l'article 8
pour les collectivités territoriales
alors bon vous allez me dire monsieur le
ministre il veut de toute façon ils
veulent réécrire donc ça c'est pas c'est
pas trop grave mais j'ai envie de vous
dire je crois qu'il faut qu'on fasse
attention et qu'il y a justement une
cohérence trouvée jusque là que la
Commission en tout cas c'est essayer de
préserver c'est pour cela que je réaimer
des avis défavorables sur ces quatre
amendements
très rapide qui seront mes derniers mots
sur ce premier débat d'abord en
rebondissant sur le dernier point
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour les
établissements publics dont vous avez
choisi de ne pas mettre de ceux dans
l'article premier
en concernant un certain nombre de
mesures vous citer celle de l'article 8
c'est exactement la même question qui va
se poser pour certains établissements
publics de petite taille je veux
simplement notifier trois points sur les
sujets qui ont été abordés d'abord sur
la question des seuils je peux
comprendre le syndrome de la page
blanche au moment de rédiger je veux
simplement dire que le seuil et la
rédaction même que nous avons choisie
c'est l'exact
rédaction qui a été adoptée par cette
assemblée sur la loi de transparence de
la vie publique de 2013 exactement la
même donc d'une certaine façon je
voudrais enlever vos préventions sur ce
sujet là troisième point il me semble
monsieur le Président Bazin qui a un
argument qui est quelque peu circulaire
vous dites au fond il faut pas prendre
les mesures pour les collectivités parce
que nous n'avons pas une bonne
connaissance
du recours aujourd'hui par les
collectivités au cabinet de conseils
mais justement la proposition de loi
dans les discussions que nous allons
avoir juste après sur les articles 3 4
et 8 permettent de faire plus de
transparence en listant les recours au
prestations par les cabinets de conseils
et puis dernier point vous dites au fond
ce sont pas exactement les mêmes enjeux
déontologiques pour l'État dans le champ
est plus large que pour un certain
nombre de collectivités c'est l'argument
que vous avez mentionné tout à l'heure
cet argument là pardon mais je ne peux
pas le partager les enjeux des
collectivités sont des enjeux de la vie
quotidienne des Français sur les
questions extrêmement centrales de
logement d'action sociale de transport
je crois que ce sont des enjeux sur
lesquels les enjeux de déontologie sont
tout aussi existants que ceux qui
concernent l'État et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle je persiste à
émettre un amendement un avis favorable
sur ces amendements
je me vois
mes chers collègues nous sommes toujours
d'accord pour finir cette nuit
nous sommes à trois quart d'heure pour
ne pas encore à Paris examiner
suffisamment
monsieur Riquier
mais je dis pour accélérer les choses
que je retire le bandeau en numéro 1 et
je retire le numéro 45 au profit du 44
entendu donc il nous reste l'amendement
24 de monsieur Sueur que je mets au bois
qui est pour
qui est contre
pas adopté
l'amendement 44 du gouvernement avec
avis défavorable de la commission qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui n'est pas adopté
résultat du scrutin votre temps 344
exprimé 331 pour le projet de la
proposition de loi 331 contre 0 la
proposition et donc adoptée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]